bonjour gérard vespière merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur
arte france jean yves le drian et
anthony blinken doivent donc
s'entretenir tout à l'heure en marge de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu que
faut-il attendre de ce face à face
et bien bonjour tout d'abord je crois
qu'il faut attendre un apaisement en
espagne dans un premier temps nous avons
eu pratiquement une semaine de
crispations
qui cache un petit peu les réalités
comme toujours l'émotion cache le
rationnel et donc le rationnel c'est que
le temps était l'ennemie de la france
nous étions en retard dans l'élaboration
des plans de construction un an un an et
demi donc les australiens n'étaient pas
satisfaits d'avoir en 2030 jusqu'en 2040
des sous-marins
donc avec une propulsion classique
diesel dans un environnement militaire
qui aurait complètement évolué et serait
parti dans la haute technologie et les
états unis in fine est aussi lutte
contre le temps vis-à-vis du
développement rapide de la force
militaire à maritime chinoise donc tout
le monde voulait aller vite et je pense
que la france a subi ce problème de
lutte contre le temps mais pourtant
avant cette rencontre entre jean yves le
drian et anthony blinken bruno le maire
le metteur en scène économie a pris la
parole il a dit chez nos confrères de
france info je cite l'épisode afghans et
l'épisode des sous-marins montrent que
nous ne pouvons plus compter sur les
états unis d'amérique pour garantir
notre protection stratégique volonté de
mettre la pression ou simple aveu
d'impuissance
moi je crois que peut-être que le
ministre des affaires économiques n'est
pas le mieux placé pour faire de la géo
stratégie la géopolitique
il n'y a pas de remplacement
stratégiques possibles si on veut être
réaliste n'est ce pas on peut toujours
envoyer des mots mais des mots ne
remplace pas des centaines de satellites
ne remplace pas des centaines d'avions
transport militaire géant que l'europe
ne possède pas et donc des dizaines de
sous marins nucléaires que la france ne
possède pas donc
ou en tout cas que l'europe la france
n'a que
3 d'un côté et les six de l'autre donc
on est dans un problème de définition
des objectifs pour la défense européenne
nous sommes dans un problème de moyens
le budget militaire des états unis et de
730 milliards de dollars le budget des
européens réunis est autour de 250
milliards de dollars 1 qui est prêt à
doubler ou à tripler le budget militaire
dans tous les pays européens personne
donc l'indépendance a un prix et nous
sommes non plus technologiquement pas
capable de le faire dans l'immédiat
mais par l indépendance on est
indépendants ou pas indépendant parce
qu'après le rendez vous téléphonique
entre joe biden emmanuel macron la
maison blanche une émision donc publié
un communiqué commun pour tenter de
restaurer la confiance mais d'après
l'opposition en france notamment la
france insoumise et le rassemblement
national on l'a vu sur les différentes
réactions aux rétablir la confiance
c'est en gros capituler comment
maintenir donc un jeu d'égal à égal avec
washington sans pratiquer la fameuse
calino thérapie
vous avez
légalité des moyens militaires il faut
laisser les militaires en parler à
partir du moment où les politiques se
hasardant de telles déclarations il faut
être très très très très prudent a donc
il n'ya pas de capacités militaires est
identique entre l'europe et les états
unis nous ne pouvons pas l'avoir non
plus dans un laps de temps court il y à
une alliance en place qui donne des
résultats qui est l'absence de guerre en
europe depuis 75 ans ce que notre
continent n'a jamais connu même du temps
des rois donc voyez vous il ya une
contribution à cette alliance
transatlantique qui a des limites qui
pose des problèmes mais qui assure la
sécurité collective et alors paris
washington ennemi ou ami et allié aux
concurrents
nous sommes alliés et donc on le sait
depuis 200 ans donc il y a ensuite sur
le plan ça c'est sûr joe politique et
sur le plan diplomatique
sur le plan industriel et bien nous
avons un fois un savoir faire nous
sommes pas les seuls il y a un
savoir-faire en italie il y en à savoir
faire en allemagne il ya un savoir-faire
en angleterre donc chacun essaye de
mettre en avant ses réalisations
militaire un industriel et les états
unis qui sont en position dominante donc
mais bien sûr la pression pour faire
adopter à leur propre matériel cela est
un jeu
dans le domaine militaire industriel que
nous retrouvons dans le domaine
industriel automobile dans le domaine
industriel aéronautique
voyez boeing et airbus et bien nous
arrivons quand même à avoir chacun une
très bonne activité
vous avez dit on et alliés dans certains
domaines
justement dans quel domaine français
américains peuvent-ils s'en en quel
domaine ils ne s'entendront jamais
peut-être là-dessus qu'ils vont
échanger nom anthony blinken et jean
yves le drian tout à l'heure et vous
savez les domaines dans lequel on
s'entend très bien c'est d'abord la
défense de l'europe qui est assurée de
façon conjointe nous entendons très bien
les états unis soucis au niveau de
l'otan régulièrement les etats-unis qui
veulent pas mettre la main à la poche on
l'a vu notamment sous la mandature de
donald trump
non là je vous faites peut-être une
petite erreur un écart entre le budget
de l'otan qui est de l'ordre de deux
milliards et demi de dollars pour payer
les fonctionnaires et le budget
militaire des états membres donc c'est
sûr le budget militaire des états
membres que les états unis comme je le
disais tout à l'heure 730 milliards de
dollars de budgets militaires américain
250 milliards de dollars pour les états
pour l'europe donc il y a effectivement
si on veut être au même niveau et bien
un problème et j'aurais rajouté la
présence et la collaboration de premier
niveau entre les etats-unis et la france
au sahel à nous sommes en collaboration
étroite avec les forces américaines a
depuis le niger depuis niamey ou à nous
opérons en conjointement des drones et
il ya une assistance logistique
américaine dans le transport dans le
ravitaillement en vol des avions qui
viennent de là de la france donc il y à
une collaboration il ya une
collaboration aussi dans le pacifique
nos bateaux se déplacent nos sous marins
se déplace à un sous-marin nucléaire
français était dans la base militaire de
guam il y a quelques mois n'est ce pas
en plein milieu du pacifique donc il ya
une collaboration
et puis nous sommes dans les affaires
maritimes et bien quelquefois le vent
souffle un peu fort mais après avoir
soufflé et bien les flots redevienne
calme merci gérard aves pierre pour
votre analyse votre décryptage rappelle
que vous êtes géopolitologue fondateurs
du web magazine le monde décrypté